Bitte schön.
Hallo schön und guten Tag.
Mehmetis ist mein Name. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja gerne.
Okay, kurz zum Ablauf.
Ich werde kurz ein paar Fragen zur Ihrer Person stellen, dann werde ich zur Ihrer Aktuellen Beschwäden kommen.
Am Ende werde ich ein paar Fragen bis zu Ihrer Familienvorgehsrichte haben.
Okay, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Martin Meyer.
Martin Meyer, können Sie bitte Ihren Nachname büsten?
Ja, also M-E-I-E-R Meyer.
M-E-I-E-R, richtig?
Ja, E-I-E-R Meyer.
Okay, Herr Meyer.
Wie ansinnst du Sie, Herr Meyer?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wie ansinnst du genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 14.5.1961.
62?
1961.
Okay.
Wie viel, sobald Sie wehgen?
Wie viel Sie aktuell wehgen?
Ja, ich wehge momentan 99 kg.
99 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,90 m.
Ja, 90, ja Sie sind sehr groß.
Und wie fühlst du uns, Herr Meyer?
Was für Bescheid.
Mir geht es nicht gut.
Irgendwie habe ich geschwindelt.
Ich habe keine Leistung mehr.
Ich bin völlig kaputt.
Ich kann seit ungefähr einem halben Jahr nicht mehr richtig schlucken.
Ein halben Jahr, Sie können nicht schlücken.
Ja, vor allem so feste Speisen kriege ich nicht runter.
Die kommen wieder raus.
Ja.
Wie lange haben Sie diese Bescheid?
Vor einem halben Jahr?
Vor einem halben Jahr.
Könntest du bitte beschwerden, Generalersalden?
Was fühlen Sie eigentlich?
Was für Begleitende Beschwerden haben Sie?
Das tut ein bisschen weh in dem Bereich, in der Brust.
Genau in der Brustmitte.
Ja, in der Brustmitte, weiter unten so Richtung, wo die Rippen anfangen,
da tut es ein bisschen weh.
Und wenn ich schlucke, geht es einfach nicht durch.
Feste Sachen, ich kann nur so sucken, vielleicht ein bisschen Flüssigkeit,
aber auch da nur immer ganz wenig.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Befindet ihr Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein oder in den Magen gegend?
Hauptsachlich.
Also wie gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, wo der Magen ist,
aber das ist genau dort, wo der Brustkopf beginnt, da tut es weh.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Schmerzen haben.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich schmerze gerade von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark
eine Schmerzung entspricht.
Also wenn Sie so fragen, wie muss ich mit denn die 10 vorstellen?
Was heißt denn 10?
10 ist unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Also so unerträglich sind Sie nicht, in dem Falle würde ich sagen,
dass es so 5 ist.
Gestrahlen Ihre Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Ob die Schmerzen ausstrahlen möchten?
Nein, das tun Sie nicht.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen da oder verschwinden Sie seitweise?
Nein, die sind immer da.
Immer da.
Wie hat sich Ihre Schmerzen mit der Zeit verändert?
Ob Sie sich verändert haben oder wie Sie sich verändert haben?
Ja, im Laufe der Zeit.
Wie hat sich Ihre Schmerzen, Ihre Schmerzen verändert?
Also das ist mit der Zeit mehr geworden.
Ist Ihre Schmerzen mit dem Nahrungsaufnahme verbunden?
Also Sie müssen auf eins aufpassen.
Wenn Sie Schmerzen sagen, dann müssen Sie plural nehmen.
Aber Sie dürfen nicht, ist Schmerzen zusammen benutzen,
das geht nicht.
Also, wie sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Nein, unabhängig von Nahrungsaufnahmen, die sind immer da.
Danke für diese Anmerkung.
Manchmal kann ich ein bisschen Fehler machen,
aber das möchte ich nicht korrigiert haben.
Gerne klar.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Ihre Schmerzen
mit der Belastung oder unter Belastung aufkommt.
Schmerzen und Belastung? Nein.
Wie gesagt, Sie sind immer da.
Ob ich mich belaste oder nicht, das macht keine Änderung.
Sie sind immer da.
Aber beim Essen spürn Sie, spürn Sie,
oder spürn Sie, brennen oder schmerzen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Es geht nur nicht durch, es bleibt da hängen
und dann kommt sie wieder raus.
Okay.
Wie machen Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost oder Kartenschweiß?
Fieber, was?
Fieber, Schütterfrost oder Kartenschweiß?
Schüttelfrost.
Nein, Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht gehabt
und Fieber habe ich auch nicht gehabt.
Gibt es Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich kann hier kaum etwas trinken.
Viel muss ich nicht auf die Toilette.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder Toiletten.
Sehr gut.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Sie erbrochen haben
oder dass Sie Überkalt haben?
Überkalt oder Berechen habe ich nicht.
Es kommt einfach so von sich raus.
Wenn ich nicht schlucken kann,
wenn ich etwas Festes gegessen habe,
dann kommt es von alleine raus ohne Überkalt.
Danke sehr.
Apetit hätte ich, ich kann nur nicht wunderschlucken.
Deswegen Sie haben keinen Apetit.
Apetit ist etwas anderes.
Wie gesagt, ich kann essen.
Ich habe auch Apetit, aber ich kann nicht schlucken.
Deswegen kann ich nicht essen.
Hat sich ihr Gehweg in Rester Zeit verändert?
Wie meint ihr es, ob ich abgenommen habe oder zugenommen habe?
Ich habe abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilo habe Sie abgenommen?
30 Kilo.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe auch noch etwas Wichtiges für die Erkrankungen.
Es gibt bestimmte Wichtiges für die Erkrankungen
von den ichwissen Hotel.
Wie meint ihr das, was für Erkrankungen?
Ich habe eine Bluthochdruck,
eine erhöhte Blutfetwerte,
eine rutsige Krankheit,
eine rutsige Krankheit.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, wobei ich in den letzten 3 Jahren
nie beim Arzt gewesen bin.
Aber ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Ich kenne keinen Blutdruck oder Diabetes.
Ich nehme keine Regen-Medikamente ein.
Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente.
Keine Vorerkrankungen auch?
Nein, Erkrankungen in dem Falle so nicht.
Ja, wurde Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, operiert wurde ich schon mal.
Ich hatte mal einen Unfall gehabt.
Da war meine Schulter gebrochen.
Das musste operiert werden.
Was ist das passiert?
Das ist mittlerweile 20 Jahre her.
20 Jahre?
Ist ihr rechts oder links Schulter getroffen?
Rechter oder link, rechte oder linke Schulter?
Das war direkt der Schulter gewesen.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Allergie und Unfallträglichkeiten?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, das bin ich bekannt.
Danke.
Ich will gerne mal ein paar Begriffe.
Ich will gerne ein paar Begriffe.
Danke.
Ich will gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ja, ich hatte geraucht.
Seit 3 Jahren rauch ich nicht mehr.
Seit 3 Jahren sind Sie nicht raucher, aber sofort?
Ja.
Bestimmt 40 Jahre.
40 Jahre lang habe ich geraucht.
Wie viel Zigaretten haben Sie geraucht?
1 Packung am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, Alkohol gar nicht.
Sehr gut.
Das ist nur eine rotunde Frage, die ich jedem stellen muss.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nein, Drogen nehme ich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt einige Fragen,
die ich Ihrer Familienfolge schichte.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in der Familie?
Sie meinen,
ob meine Eltern eine Krankheit hatten?
Ja.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste,
ob mein Vater ein Blutdruck hatte
oder meine Mutter ein Diabetes.
Aber das habe ich nicht mehr so im Kopf so richtig.
Sie sind vor Jahren verstorben.
Woran sind Sie gestorbene?
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Meine Mutter hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Er ist daran verstorben.
Mein heistlicher Beileid.
Was für Bildungsabhängen haben Sie?
Was sind Sie vom Bildungsabhängen?
Was ich vom Bildungsabhängen habe,
ist, dass ich nicht mehr so gut bin.
Was sind Sie vom Bildungsabhängen?
Was ich vom Bildungsabhängen habe,
ist, dass ich Elektromeister war.
Ich war Elektromeister.
Das klingt aber schön.
Haben Sie sich das bei der Arbeit?
Nein, ich mag eigentlich meinen Beruf.
Das ist sehr gut,
wenn ein Mann seinen Beruf hat.
Haben Sie Kinder? Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe zwei Söhne.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, wunderschön.
Ich bin für mich
wichtige Fragen durch.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben
oder etwas nicht verstehen haben,
können Sie mir gerne sagen.
Können Sie mich gerne fragen?
Nein, ich habe Fragen in der Form nicht.
Aber habe ich Krebs?
Ja, wir haben Krebs.
Wir haben Krebs.
Aber wir sollten erst mal nicht
auf die Arbeit gehen.
Wir sollten erst mal nicht
an die Schlimmheit denken.
Wir sollten erst mal durchgeführt werden.
Ich habe bei Google nachgeschaut.
Ich habe Angst bekommen.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie Söge haben.
Aber ehrlich gesagt,
wir haben das Krebs nicht ausgeschliessen.
Aber das Pro
weitere Schritte, weitere Untersuchungen
müssen durchgeführt werden.
Um etwas genauer
zu werden.
Okay, gut.
Dann haben wir ja
erst körperlich untersuchen.
Ich brauche auch Labo-Untersuchungen.
Ich habe auch Labo-Untersuchungen.
Ich werde bei Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Wir benötigen auch verschiedene
Bildgerände,
die zum Beispiel
Regenaufnahme.
Ich werde gleich mit meinem
Oder-Arsch sprechen und wieder bei Ihnen sein.
Können Sie mir auch ein paar
weitere Schritte machen?
Ich habe keine Allergien.
Ich werde meinen Kollege Bescheid geben.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben,
was auf dem Aufnahme ist,
dann können Sie mir etwas geben.
Ich werde meine Kollegin Bescheid geben.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben,
was auf dem Aufnahme ist,
dann können Sie mir etwas geben.
Ich möchte Ihnen etwas geben.
Die Elektrika weiß man,
wenn die Infrastruktur nicht gut ist.
Sie wissen das schon.
Wenn es geht.
Es geht um Strahlung.
Aber Sie wollen zu wenig Strahlung ausgesetzt sein.
Deswegen soll ich eine kleine Sorge machen.
Es wird sehr schnell durchführbare Untersuchungen.
Deswegen brauchen wir eine Vorbereitung dafür.
Was wollen Sie in Röntgen? Die Lunge, oder?
Ja, für Thorak.
Gebrust Gegend, ich werde Aufnahme machen.
Wir wollen von der Brust einen Röntgen machen.
Dann, wenn Sie keine weitere Fragen haben,
ich will mit meiner Oda spielen.
Nein, keine weiteren Fragen.
Alles Gute.
Danke.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe Herma ja.
Leiden Sie unter Heiser Kart?
Nein, nicht.
Wussten Sie?
Bitte.
Noch zwei Fragen.
Haben Sie aufstoffen oder dort gebläht?
Sie meinen jetzt oder früher?
Jetzt oder früher?
Aufstoßen, jetzt habe ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich nicht flucken kann,
dann kommt es manchmal von alleine hoch.
Aber wenn Sie so aufstoßen sagen,
das habe ich früher viele, viele Jahre gehabt, das weiß ich.
Haben Sie einen herbeschweiten Donner?
Nach dem Aufstoßen meinen Sie, oder?
Aufstoßen oder Schluckbeschweite?
Nein, wie gesagt, nur aufstoßen, aber keine Großschmerzen.
Wie ist die Farbe Ihres Stuttges?
Die Farbe des Stuttges, ganz normal.
Leiden Sie unter Heiser Kart?
Nein, mit dem Herzen habe ich eigentlich kein Problem.
Ja, okay.
Bitte.
Eine Frage.
Haben Sie fremdgefühl am Hals?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Verspüren Sie, wie ein fremdgefühl am Hals
während Schlucken, beim Schlucken,
wie Globensgefühl?
Als Bereiche.
Als Bereiche habe ich kein Problem.
Okay, danke.
Noch eine Frage, Kollegen.
Noch eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Sind Ihnen geschwollene Leftknoten am Hals ausgefallen?
Ich habe mich zwar nie untersucht, aber mir ist nichts aufgefallen.
Danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Diese Schmerzen waren Sie beim Arzt?
Nein, ich war damit bisher noch bei keinem Arzt.
Und andere Frage, haben Sie schon bemerkt, dass Sie Szenen haben?
Dass ich was habe, bitte?
Szenen im Händen.
Dass die Hände so ein bisschen zittrig sind?
Nee, warum?
Eine Verdachtdiagnose, deswegen möchte ich fragen.
Okay, nee, dann habe ich nicht.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich vielleicht würdungsfrei?
Zwei Fragen, Herr Legen.
Noch mal bitte die Frage.
Jürgen.
Lieber.
Jürg-Reiz.
Nee, Jürg-Reiz habe ich nicht.
Und noch andere Fragen?
Ja, eine Frage, bitte.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie früher häufig nachts aufwachen wegen Aufstotzen,
zum Beispiel?
Ob ich nachts wegen...
Ob ich nachts aufgestanden bin, gesagt.
Nur, wenn ich Bät viel getrunken habe, oder so, aber sonst nicht.
Na, bitte, aber das war nicht.
Alle Fragen, fertig, Kollegen, oder?
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Ja, bitte.
Fühlen Sie sich manchmal sehr schnell wütend sein?
Ob ich mich öfters müde fühle?
Nein, wütend.
Ich frage mich nicht, wütend.
Ja, wütend.
Wütend.
Nee, wütend, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nee, ich bin eigentlich ein ganz gelassener Mensch.
Ich bin ein sehr gelassener Mensch.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben gesagt, sie sind die Schwinder.
Sie haben die Schwange, die Blöde, die Blöde, die Blöde.
Das ist ein bisschen Schwangschwinder.
Schwangschwinder.
Und diese Schmerzen haben Kollegen gefragt,
beschreiben, ich take in die Dürre Kunt oder uns so weiter.
Ich habe gesagt, ich renne, renne das Schmerz.
Ich renne das Schmerz.
Okay.
Ich denke, alle Fragen, die ich hier hat, hocam.
Können wir als erstes, das ist ein Anfang?
Können wir.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, Herr Orvers.
Ich habe einen Patient, namens Martin Meyer.
Er ist 63 Jahre alt, 99 kg schwer und 1,90 m groß.
1,90 m.
Wenn man 1,90 m sagt, kommen dann keine 10 m.
Ja.
1,90 m groß.
Richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Er hat sich wegen seines halben Jahres bestehenden,
progredierten, assistieren, brennen,
oder Bauchschmerzen vorgestellt.
Und die vorgehenden Begleitzentrums,
die Patienten aufgefallen,
sind in der Zeit,
die die Erbärmung von 30 kg in 6 Monaten
und durch Abpatenz Gewichtsverlust
und Schwindel,
die Vertraut.
Ja.
Er hat seine Schmerzen auf Schmerzen,
5 von 10 bewertet.
An Vorerkrankungen gab es keine Auffälligkeiten,
aber er sei vor 20 Jahren an Rechner Schulter operiert worden.
Es gibt keine regelmäßig eingenommenen Medikamente
und keine bekannten Allergen
und keine Bekannte.
Und seit 3 Jahren sei er nicht Raucher,
aber so vor gibt es ein bekannte 40-Packjahrs-Rauchen-Geschichte.
Sie trinken keinen Alten.
Raucher an einem Nese, ja.
40 Paar Rechner.
Sie haben auch einen Rauchen-Geschichte.
Sie trinken keinen Alten.
Raucher an einem Nese, ja.
Und 40 Paar Rechner.
Ja, 40 Paar Rechner.
Sie haben auch Druck und Anamnesen verneut.
In der Familie an einem Nese fand er sich beim Vater,
der an Schlaganfall gestorben ist.
Ich will mich korrigieren,
erst mal, sein Vater ist sei an Schlaganfall gestorben,
sei mutter sei an Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Er ist ein Ekonomist von der Familie,
von der Familie verheiratet und so weiter.
Ja.
Wir haben auch einen Anker von einem Verbrauch.
Das ist ein
Wenn Sie von Sklerodermie sprechen, hat der dann irgendwelche Anzeichen dafür oder gibt er dann irgendwelche Symptome an, die für eine Sklerodermie sprechen könnten?
Ja, ich wollte nur als Fernseherdiagnose diese Krakenheit nennen.
Ja, das kann man wirklich sagen. Und als die andere, ich kann vielleicht...
Sie müssen aufpassen, wenn Sie irgendeine Differenzialdiagnose in den Raum werfen, müssen Sie sich mit dieser Krankheit auskennen,
weil sonst wären Sie darüber gefragt und wenn Sie sich darüber nicht gut auskennen.
Ja, ja, das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Das sollte ich nicht sagen, aber das habe ich für mich von meiner...
Ja, okay, ja, also...
Aus Sklerod, ja.
Also, die Tatsache ist, dass er einfach eine Schluckstörung hat, also eine Düsselvagehen.
Ja, und der hat dadurch Gewicht verloren.
Und jetzt liegt es an uns herauszufinden, was das Problem ist.
Ob das jetzt ein Tumor in der Speiseröhre ist oder woanders, das muss ich erst mal zeigen.
Gut. Was machen wir jetzt mit dem?
Also zur Abklärung würde ich gerne Özefage, Gastrodynamik und Kopie, aber vorher,
ich würde gerne nach der kömpelischen Untersuchung und Labor-Untersuchung,
sonst kann...
Rund der Aufnahme, ich würde Erfolg als Wohl sind.
Warum möchten Sie einen Röntgen machen?
Ja, ich würde erst mal sehen, ob es ein Tumor da ist oder...
Also in dem Falle würde ich das Röntgen jetzt erst mal hinten anstellen,
weil er kann nicht runterschlucken.
Und die wichtigste Untersuchung in dem Falle ist tatsächlich eine
Ösofagogastrodinoskopie oder ÖGD, wie man im Deutsch sagt.
Damit man einmal sieht, was ist da los?
Weil Röntgen brauchen Sie den in dem Falle jetzt erst mal nicht.
Wenn der jetzt andere Probleme hätte ohne ÖSFG,
und Sie hätten eine ÖGD gemacht und nichts gefunden,
dann macht es Sinn, vielleicht ein Röntgen zu machen,
vielleicht sogar eine Schnittbildgebung zu machen.
Aber in jetzigen, bei diesem Herrn würde ich jetzt erst mal
keinen Röntgen machen, erst mal eine ÖGD machen.
Aber das ist ein Patient, der gibt Schmerzen an,
was muss man da formal auf jeden Fall noch machen?
Patient, ich sollte... Können Sie bitte das Herz nochmal?
Der Mann gibt ja auch Schmerzen an, in dem Bereich,
in dem Bereich Epigastrium, soweit ich verstanden habe.
Was müssen Sie mit dem noch machen?
Worauf müssen Sie da achten, wenn er mit Schmerzen im Brustkorb kommt?
Ich sollte EKG schreiben, Sie meinen?
Ja, na klar.
Ja, Sie müssen ein EKG schreiben.
Sie müssen auch im Labor einmal gucken,
ob irgendwelche Herzentzymien erhöht sind oder nicht.
Sprich, Sie müssen nach einem Herzinfarkt einmal schauen,
nicht, dass der sowohl eine Dysphagie,
aber auch ein Herzproblem hat.
Er sagt, weiß es nicht, aber er hat geraucht.
Also ein Risikofaktor.
Die Mutter ist am Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich bin ein bisschen heute extrem müde deswegen,
aber das sollte ich nicht feig, ich weiß es noch.
Ja, na klar, deswegen wiederholen wir das.
Ist ja alles nicht so schlimm.
Also Sie müssen immer dran denken, wenn jemand mit Brustschmerzen kommt,
müssen Sie immer an einen Herzinfarkt denken.
Und das müssen Sie einmal mit EKG und mit Labor einmal ausschließen.
Sie sollten jetzt keine Infarktausschluss machen,
aber einmal schauen, ob im EKG es die Hebungen da sind
oder im Labor zum Beispiel LDH erhöht ist,
ob da eine CK-Erhöhung da ist oder CKMW.
Und wenn das alles unauffällig ist,
dann können Sie erst mal sagen,
nee, die Schmerzen kommen nicht vom Herzen.
Und Sie sind schon mal auf der sicheren Seite.
Gut, jetzt wollen Sie eine ÖGD machen.
Was benutzen Sie denn vorher mit diesen Menschen machen,
bevor Sie eine ÖGD machen können?
Vielleicht Ende Sonographie können wir machen,
aber meines die Blutuntersuch?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Alle Untersuchungen hier in Deutschland
setzen voraus, dass Sie den Patienten vorher aufgeklärt haben müssen.
Ja, Sie müssen ihn aufklären.
Das heißt, wenn jemand mit solchen Beschwerden kommt
und Sie müssen bei dem eine ÖGD machen,
dann müssen Sie den direkt in der Notaufnahme,
wenn Sie den sehen, direkt für eine ÖGD aufklären.
Ihm erklären, wie so eine ÖGD abläuft,
weil ein normaler Mensch weiß doch nicht,
wie er eine endoskopisch Untersuchung abläuft.
Dann müssen Sie dann die geeignete Aufklärung...
Noch mal bitte.
Ja, ich würde gerne den Versuch unternehmen
und ich wollte sagen,
wie müssen während...
soll ich anfangen und sagen?
Ja, machen Sie das.
Diese Aufklärung, Frage,
kommen auch in der Verschmackberufung.
Deswegen habe ich mich dafür ein bisschen...
Ich habe vorher ein bisschen dafür gelesen,
ich wollte jetzt...
Ja, dann erklären Sie mal.
Wie läuft denn so eine ÖGD ab?
Erklärte Sie mich mal auf.
Mit Hilfe eines beaksamen, dünnen Schläges,
wir werden diesen Schlägen durch den Mundhöhe
bis in die Magen, innen,
verschieben und mit einem so genannten Industrie,
mit diesem Kamera, innenorgane sehen,
aber wir können vielleicht ein...
vorher für diese...
Ja, das sollte ich nochmal lesen, aber...
Also, wenn Sie jemanden für eine ÖGD aufklären,
müssen Sie dem einfach nur erzählen,
dass das ein flexibler Schlauch ist.
Ein flexibler Schlauch, der vorne eine Kamera hat.
Und dieser Schlauch lässt sich durch ein Zahn...
Seilzüge und ein Zahnrad in die gewünschte Richtung lenken.
Man kann das in alle Richtungen bewegen,
sodass man Organe von Speiseröhre bis Magen
und 12-Fingerdamen von innen überall anschauen kann.
Und wenn irgendetwas auffälliges da ist,
können Sie über diesen Endoskop,
über diesen Schlauch auch kleinste Werkzeuge vorschieben.
Worüber Sie dann auch eine Probe entnehmen können.
Oder aber bei Blutungen die Blutung stillen können.
Ja, das ist nur dazu.
Aber Sie müssen auch den Patienten über mögliche Risiken aufklären,
denen darauf hinweisen.
Was ist die größte Gefahr bei einer ÖGD
oder bei einer endoskopischen, oberen endoskopischen Untersuchung?
Ja, meistens passiert es, dass die Leute einfach,
wenn sie sediert sind, drauf beißen und Zahn ausfallen.
Ja, deswegen sagt man, Leute, die Prothesen haben,
müssen ihre Prothesen vorher rausnehmen.
Wenn die nämlich einmal in den Rachen fallen,
dann hat man ein Problem.
Ja, die müssen dann dem Patienten sagen,
haben Sie eine totale Prothese oder Teilprothese,
nehmen Sie sie bitte ab vor der Untersuchung.
Und Sie müssen wissen, mit der Endoskopie können Zähne ausfallen,
die dann angeatmet werden können und so weiter.
Wenn Sie weiter vorschieben,
können Sie natürlich die Speiseröhre verletzen,
perforieren, es kann zu Blutungen kommen, zu Infektionen.
Oder?
Bitte noch mal.
Vielleicht Heiserkeit nach der Untersuchung?
Ja, klar, es kann auch eine Heiserkeit geben, auf jeden Fall.
Und darüber müssen Sie den Patienten aufklären.
Und im schlimmsten Falle, wenn die Blutung zu stark ist,
dass sie dann auch Transfusionen erhalten müssen.
Und wenn es ganz, ganz schlimm wird,
dass sie dann eventuell auch respiratorisch insuffizient werden,
vielleicht auf die Intensivstation gehen,
vielleicht beatmet werden müssen.
Ja, das sind so die wichtigsten Sachen,
auf die man eigentlich den Patienten hinweisen sollte.
Aber das dürfen Sie nie vergessen.
Nicht einfach sagen, ich mache eine ÖGD,
Sie sagen einfach, ich kläre den Patienten
über mögliche Risiken
und die Durchführung einer ÖGD auf.
Dann brate ich den vor, leg dem eine Nadel,
nehmen Kurzblut ab
und schaue nach den gerinnungswerten Laborparameter.
Und dann melde ich Ihnen in der Endoskopie für eine ÖGD an.
Damit derjenige, indem Sie das dann erzählen,
in der Prüfung auch weiß,
oh, dem sind die Abläufe, die Schritte,
sehr, sehr genau bekannt.
Danke für die schöne Informationen,
wie Sie uns gegeben haben.
Kein Problem.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie eine ÖGD gemacht.
Also, die ÖG haben Sie gemacht,
Sie haben Labor angeguckt, Herzinfarkt hat der Mensch nicht.
Und jetzt haben Sie ihn aufgeklärt
und schicken ihn zur ÖGD.
So.
Und der Gastroenterologe sagt,
ruft sie an und sagt,
im distalen Sofagus,
im Übergang von der Speiseröhre
zum Magen, hat er einen
nicht-passierbaren Tumor.
Oder auf Deutsch gesagt oder medizinisch gesagt,
ein fast total stenoisierender Tumor
im unteren Sofagus.
Und er hat daraus mehrere Biopsien entnommen.
Ja.
Gut.
Was machen wir jetzt mit dem?
Wir haben Proberentnahme gemacht, oder?
Ja, Proberentnahme sind erfolgt, ja.
Ja, dann, wir haben gesehen,
dass ob ein Adenocarcinum da liegt, oder?
Ja, das wissen wir ja noch gar nicht.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Also, wir werden jetzt warten,
dass der Pathologe die Proben erstmal aufarbeitet.
Und dann wissen wir, ob das ein Adenocarcinum ist
oder ob das ein Plattenepithelocarcinum ist.
Das ist ein anderes.
Aber das braucht er ein paar Tage.
Und was machen wir denn jetzt bis dahin?
Ja, eine...
Ja, es ist halt wie so eine Stationeaufnahme
und so halt...
Ja, dem müssen Sie sowieso stationär aufnehmen.
Von Anfang an, ja, als der sich in der Notaufnahme vorgestellt hat
mit diesen Beschwerden,
müssen Sie den aufnehmen.
Das ist eine stationäre Aufnahme.
Der ist auf dem Stationen jetzt.
Sie haben eine ÖGD gemacht
und der Gastroenterologe oder der Endoskopiker sagt,
der hat einen stenosierenden Tumor
im distalen Pesofagus.
Ist das so?
Gastrodolodon, Sonder, wie können Sie Sonder
um zwei Zugänge anlegen?
Zwei Zugänge, Sie machen Brownylen,
und das ist das, was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, das können Sie gerne machen.
Und für diese Vitaminssuffer
oder so irgendeine Elektrolys-Suffer?
Ja, das können Sie machen, aber das ist alles erst mal irrelevant.
Sie möchten ganz schnell mit der Erkrankung
voranschreiten oder vorankommen.
Was müssen Sie dann machen, wenn Sie bei jemandem
einen Tumor finden?
Was gehört automatisch dazu?
Das ist in der Regel nicht so gut,
sondern es ist nicht so, dass Sie es nicht mehr machen.
Sie haben es nicht mehr geschrieben,
korrekterweise.
Das fällt mir nicht ein.
Ein Staging, sagen wir dazu, ein Staging machen.
Staging bedeutet Schnittbildgebung.
Eine Computertomographie
vom Brust und Baub.
Das ist ja einmal Lunge,
ob da irgendwelche Lymphknoten da sind,
ob da irgendwelche Metastasen vorliegen.
Sie machen natürlich eine Computertomographie vom Bauch,
damit Sie einmal sehen, ob im Bauchraum
zum Beispiel eine Peritoneal-Metastase vorliegt
oder eine Lebermetastasierung vorliegt
oder ob vielleicht irgendwelche Gefäße
verschlossen sind oder nicht.
Also ein Staging machen.
Ich habe es schon mal gesehen.
Ist das richtig?
Zugänge legen oder Zugange legen?
Zugänge legen, sagt man. Zugang legen, nicht anlegen.
Zugang legen heißt irgendwo reinlegen.
Anlegen heißt danebendun.
Angelegt, angelehnt zum Beispiel.
Zugang legen, sagt man, nicht anlegen.
Das ist schon richtig.
Jetzt haben Sie ein CT gemacht
und der Radiologe sagt,
er sieht eine Verdickung im Bereich des distalen
Esophagus, aber er sieht keine Metastasen.
Dann habe ich schon einen.
Jetzt warten wir auf den pathologischen Befund.
Der Pathologe sagt,
das ist ein AD-Nokazinob.
Ihre Verbindung ist nicht so gut.
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Ich habe gesagt, wir können eine Tomer Rezession
mit dem Tomer Rezession aufhalten, oder?
Nein, nein, also Sie müssen ganz bestimmte Schritte durchführen.
Und dazu gehört,
dass man die Anlegerung,
die man in der Anlegerung hat,
und dazu gehört, dass man bei einem Tumor
im Bereich des Esophagus oder im Bereich des Magens
auch eine Endosonografie macht.
Zwar sagt der Radiologe,
der Tumor ist nicht passierbar,
aber eine Endosonografie würde ich auf jeden Fall
nochmal versuchen.
Das gehört mit dazu.
Sie sehen dann, ob zum Beispiel Lymphknoten drumherum befallen sind
und ob der Tumor sämtliche Wandschichten
infiltriert oder durch Bord oder nicht.
Wenn Sie einen kleinen Tumor hätten, zum Beispiel
ein T1 oder so, dann hätte man den direkt operieren können.
Aber ab einem Tumor T3
oder T2 mit Lymphknoten befallen,
müssen Sie erst eine sogenannte
Neo-Adjuvante-Chemotherapie machen.
Nicht sofort operieren.
Sie haben gesagt, dass das nur ein Tumor und keine Metastase da ist.
Deswegen habe ich das nicht.
Aber CT ist nicht 100% zuverlässig.
Kleinere Lymphknoten kann das CT manchmal nicht darstellen.
Das ist nicht der Pathologe.
Weil der Pathologe kann keine Lymphknoten kontrollieren.
Das sind ja nur Biopsien aus dem Tumor selber.
Sie müssen sich jetzt einmal auf die Wandschicht konzentrieren.
Einmal gucken, wie tief der Tumor von gewachsen ist.
Ob das ein T1, T2, T3 oder vielleicht sogar ein T4 Tumor ist.
Und ob drumherum Lymphknotenbefall vorliegt oder nicht.
Ein sogenanntes Staging.
Und abhängig davon, wenn es ein Lymphknotenbefall gibt
oder mindestens ein T2-Tumor oder T3-Tumor,
dann müssen Sie eine Neodövante Chemotherapie planen.
Und wenn Sie ein größeres Haus haben,
dann müssen Sie noch einen Schritt dazwischenschalten.
Das wäre eine Tumor-Bord Vorstellung.
Sie müssen den Chirurgen einmal darüber informieren,
dass Sie so einen Patienten haben.
Und da geht es darum, dass der Chirur eine zusätzliche Untersuchung
noch machen muss.
Das wäre eine diagnostische Lapparoscopie.
Weil das CT ist nicht 100%ig verlässlich.
Auch ein MRT würde keine 100%ige Sicherheit bringen.
Deswegen sagen die Leitlinien eine Bauchspiegelung machen,
eine diagnostische Lapparoscopie, einmal das Peritoneum anbucken.
Ob da irgendwelche Metastasien sind,
Hinweise dafür vorliegen oder nicht.
Und nur wenn die Lapparoscopie unauffällig ist,
dann macht man die Neodövante Chemotherapie.
Und für die Neodövante Chemotherapie braucht man auch
einen dauerhaften Zugang,
weil bestimmte Substanzen über mehrere Tage
kontinuierlich gegeben werden müssen.
Dann legt man gleich einen Procht.
Einen venösen Procht entweder rechte Schulter oder linke Schulter,
pectoral über die venasubklavia geht dann bis zum rechten Vorwurf,
die Spitze.
Und das macht der Chirurg dann meistens zusammen mit der
diagnostischen Lapparoscopie.
Jetzt haben Sie alles gemacht.
Der Chirurg sagt, die diagnostische Lapparoscopie
ist unauffällig, keine Peritonearkarzenose.
Der Port liegt.
Und jetzt schicken Sie den Herrn zu einer Neodövante Chemotherapie.
Haben Sie mal darüber was gehört?
Ja.
Aber die Substanzen werden Ihnen wahrscheinlich nicht so geläufig sein.
Da fragt jemand, ob man einen Stent legt.
Einen Stent würde ich jetzt da nicht reinlegen,
weil das ist ein Stent.
Das würde einfach nur alles kompliziert machen,
weil der Thoma macht erstens Schmerzen.
Der Thoma könnte durch den Druck von dem Stent
auch zu einer Perforation führen.
Das macht alles nur komplizierter.
Und als Onkologe weiß ich manchmal wirklich Chemotherapie
sehr schnell und der Thoma wird kleiner und die Patienten
können wieder schlucken.
Und dann brauche ich auch kein Stent.
Aber jetzt einmal zu dem Namen der Erkrankung.
Wie würden Sie denn jetzt die Krankheit nennen?
Ja, haben wir nicht Thoma gesagt, oder?
Ja, das ist zwar ein Karzinom, aber wie heißt denn dieses Karzinom?
Ja, ja, von Adeno-Karzinom gesagt, oder?
Ja, Adeno-Karzinom.
Und was ist es dann?
Ist es ein Ösofagus-Karzinom?
Es ist ein Ösofagus-Karzinom.
Ist es ein Magen-Karzinom?
Oder wie bezeichnet man dieses Karzinom?
Ja, es ist ein Ösofagus-Karzinom.
Ja, genau darum geht es.
Das wollte ich einmal hier erklärt haben.
Früher hat man Adeno-Karzinome immer zu Magen-Karzinomen gezählt.
Man hat gesagt, im Ösofagus gibt es kein Adeno-Karzinom.
Alles, was Adeno-Karzinom ist, ist Magen-Karzinom.
Und wenn jemand viel Reflux hat, kommt es über Meta-Plasin,
über Barrett, immer zu Adeno-Karzinomen.
Und da hat man gesagt, das ist formal ein Magen-Karzinom.
In den letzten Jahren hat man gesagt,
nee, das ist nicht ganz korrekt.
Man hat daraus eine eigene Krankheit gemacht.
Ein Adeno-Karzinom des Ösofagus-Gastralen-Übergangs.
Oder ein AEG, wird abgekürzt, ein AEG,
wie die Firma Elektrogeräte herstellt, AEG.
Und das wird unterteilt in eins, zwei und drei.
Dabei ist eins ein Tumor, ein Adeno-Karzinom im Ösofagus.
Ein zweier ist genau in der Mitte
und ein dreier liegt überwiegend im Magen bereit.
Nur, dass Sie Bescheid wissen.
Mittlerweile sagen jetzt manche Experten,
ach, das ist völliger Unfug.
Wenn es im Ösofagus liegt, ist es ein Ösofagus-Karzinom.
Man muss dann aber sagen, kein Plattenepithes,
sondern eine Adeno-Karzinom.
Deswegen ist das auch nicht falsch.
Nur, dass Sie das schon mal gehört haben.
Dass Sie dann sagen, es gibt auch ein Adeno-Karzinom
im distalen Ösofagus, was früher als Adeno-Karzinom
des Ösofagugastralen-Übergangs bezählt wurde
oder benannt wurde, bezeichnet wurde.
Nur, dass Sie das schon mal gehört haben.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ein bisschen zu schwer, oder was?
Nein, das ist sehr gut. Dankeschön.
Eine Haupttitel Adeno-Karzinom, aber zum Beispiel
Magin-Karzinom, Kolom-Karzinom, Ösofagus-Karzinom,
Allens-Adeno-Karzinom.
Richtig.
Ja, richtig. Aber das hat einen ganz besonderen Namen.
Man hat das früher als Adeno-Karzinom des Ösofagugastralen-Übergangs bezeichnet,
weil im Englischen Ösofagus mit E geschrieben wird.
Esophageal heißt es A-E-G, Adeno-Karzinom
auf Ösofagugastral-Übergang.
Und deshalb hat man das früher als A-E-G-1 bezeichnet gehabt.
Aber heutzutage sagt man dazu auch ein distales
Ösofagus-Karzinom, Adeno-Karzinom,
distales, ösofagiales, Adeno-Karzinom.
Nur, dass man das schon mal gehört hat, dass man nicht in der Falle
tappt und dann sagt, ja, Ösofagus-Karzinom sind nur Platinepidé-Karzinome.
Das ist nicht korrekt.
Danke schön.
Welche Unterricht habe ich, Odino-Fagi oder Dysfagi?
Und Dysfagi.
Also, Dysfagi bedeutet, dass man Schluckstörungen hat.
Ja, Dys ist immer eine Störung.
Das bedeutet, manchmal geht rein und manchmal geht nicht durch.
Ja, und wenn es ein Stopp ist, dann hat man eine Schluckstörung
oder überhaupt kein Schlucken mehr möglich.
Ja, Odino-Fagi, ja, den Begriff habe ich bestimmt in meinem Leben
noch nie benutzt.
Dysfagi ist eher das, was man häufig benutzt.
Die Patienten geben auch eine Schluckstörung an
und alles andere interessiert eigentlich nicht.
Okay, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Der Patient hat gesagt, Leistungsferlus, Müdigkeit.
Ja, ja.
Im Arsatzgeschichte können wir eine medizinische Wörter fatuki nennen.
Oder einfach Leistungsfermin der Müdigkeit.
Ja, Leistungsknick oder Leistungsabfall.
Fatik würde ich jetzt so nicht bezeichnen, weil eine Fatik
ist ein ganz besonderer Begriff, der bei unkologischen Patienten
immer nach einer Operation, nach einer Chemotherapie immer angewendet wird.
Bei einer Diagnostik von einer Fatik zu sprechen,
wäre für mich ein bisschen zu viel.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich nicht ganz sinnvoll.
Ich würde beim Arzt zu Arztgespräch sagen, der Patient gibt
einen zunehmenden Leistungsabfall oder Leistungsknick
oder Leistungsschwäche an.
Okay.
Und der Patient hat gesagt, nach der Einnahme eine Nicht-Emerzis,
Nicht-Übelkeit, aber Registration, können wir ja nennen, Registration.
Ja, Registration.
Na klar.
Ja, also er bricht, es kommt alles auf einmal hoch.
Er bricht es auf einmal raus, ohne Protromie, sagt man,
ohne dass er Übelkeit hat.
Warum?
Es wird einfach retrograd wieder rausgeschmissen, was nicht
vorwärts geht, was am Tumor hängen bleibt.
Wahrscheinlich ist dann auch der Esophagus so ein bisschen
dilatiert bei ihm und das sammelt sich dort und irgendwann,
wenn es nicht vorwärts geht, dann kommt mit einer
Regurgitation gleich wieder raus.
Deswegen muss man diesen Patienten eigentlich auch sagen,
er soll erst mal bis auf kleinste Mengen Flüssigkeit
erst mal nicht versuchen zu essen, damit er nicht aspiriert,
weil das wäre wiederum eine Komplikation, die man nicht
haben möchte.
Okay.
Deswegen auf gesilte Nachfragen, zum Beispiel, der Patient hat
gesagt, Husten, Heiserkeit und so weiter, verneint.
Richtig.
Ja, sehr gut.
Na klar, immer fragen, ob er nach dem Essen irgendwie immer
Hustenreiz hat und ob er nachts zum Beispiel aus dem
Schlaf heraus mit Hustenreiz aufwacht und ob das häufiger
vorkommt oder ob das mal vorgekommen ist.
Was sollte man schon fragen oder ob eine Heiserkeit war?
Eine Heiserkeit kann natürlich mit der Asperation,
mit der Schädigung der Stimmbänder einhergehen,
aber auch mit zum Beispiel einem Lymphknoten, der den
nervus laryngialis Rekorrenz irgendwie schädigt und
dadurch eine Lehmung des Stimmbannes hervorruft.
Da habe ich eine Frage stellen.
Ja?
Ja, in diesem Fall können wir als Diagnostisch einfach röntgen
mit Kontrastmittel durchführen lassen, um die Schluckfunktion
anzuschauen.
Ne, würde ich nicht machen.
Warum nicht?
Ich hatte es eben gerade erwähnt, weil wenn er bestimmte
Sachen nicht schlucken kann und sie geben dem
Kontrastmittel da rein, dann bringen sie ihnen Gefahr,
weil er aspirieren kann.
Okay, aber der Patient sagte, die Schmerzen beim
Schlucken, er sagte, es gibt keine ganze Schluckfunktion
Verlust, oder?
Teilweise, er kann Feste sagen nicht schlucken,
keine festen Sachen schlucken, nur Flüsse.
Deswegen, sagt er, ich vielleicht ein paar Runden gerne.
Das bringt sie ja nicht weiter.
Das bringt sie ja nicht weiter, weil sie wollen ja
vorankommen und deswegen ist es wichtig, dass sie die
Endoskopie favorisieren, mit Röntgen aufhalten.
Hier in Deutschland ist es so, dass sie, wenn jemand mit
Hygdysfagie kommt, Gewichtsverlust, dass dann, wenn sie in Richtung
Suffagus oder Magen denken, dass die sofort die Endoskopie
ihnen Vordergrund stellen.
Das ist das A und O.
Deswegen hatte ich vorhin auch explizit erklärt, wenn so
jemand kommt, da müssen sie den ganz schnell für eine ÖGD
aufklären, alles in die Wege leiten, dass man so schnell
wirklich einfach mal in die Speiseröhre Magen reinguckt,
dass da irgendein Hindernis da ist oder nicht.
Die Bildgebung, weitere Abklärung ist zwei dran.
Okay, diese Funktion des Röntgen mit Kontrastmittel
ist so fremd für mich, aber im Kurs haben wir gelernt,
der ARTS, ein ARTS hat uns gesagt, erst mal sollen wir
einfach Röntgen mit Kontrastmittel durchführen lassen
und dann erst mal die ÖGD endoskopien.
Das ist falsch.
Sie müssen sich die Leitlinien angucken und es gibt keine
Empfehlung für ein ÖGD-Bereichlub und in manchen Krankenhäusern
wird dieser Dienst auch gar nicht mehr angeboten.
Ich weiß nicht, wie alt dieser ARTS gewesen ist in dem Kurs.
Das ist eine ganz veraltete Methode von vor 20 Jahren,
wo ÖGDs nicht so häufig waren und wo die Leute nicht so viel Erfahrung hatten.
Ja, er ist so alt.
Ich habe so einen...
Herz, fertig, met up.
Okay.
Also an B-Symptomatik gibt der Patienten nur Gewichtsverlust.
Der Patient in der...
im Anfang, retrosternale Schmerzen oder Oberbauchschmerzen?
Retrosternale Schmerzen, der Herr hat immer wieder gesagt,
wo der Brustkorb anfängt.
Ja.
Also so Epigastrium, nicht eher weiter hoch, retrosternale Schmerzen.
Das muss eben der ARTS so interpretieren, verstehen.
Manchmal ist es auch wichtig, wenn man den Patienten untersucht,
dass man da auch mal drauf drückt und sagt, zeigen Sie mal,
wo ist er in der Schmerz?
Wenn Sie den Patienten untersuchen, dann wollen Sie ja wissen,
wo ordnet der Patient das dann an?
Dass Sie sagen, ich will mal drücken, sagen Sie mir mal,
ob ich den Schmerz mit Druck auslösen kann.
Ist es im Epigastrium, ist es retrosternal,
wird das durch die Rippen ausgelöst,
wird das durch Atmung ausgelöst oder nicht?
Das kann man erfragen, aber man sitzt den Patienten gegenüber,
dann drückt man einmal drauf und sagt, ist es hier,
ist der Schmerz hier, ja oder nein?
Und am Ende sagt man, der Patient gibt retrosternale Schmerzen an,
die nicht auf Druck auslösbar sind,
die nicht atemauslösbar sind und die auch nicht bewegungshaftig sind.